in 1955 the average price of a movie
ticket was 73 cents today it's about
nine dollars this phenomenon is called
inflation the increase in prices of
goods and services across an economy
over time it refers to everything you
buy from groceries to doctors visits to
homes inflation is among the most
powerful forces in the economy and
financial markets too much or too little
can send the economy spiraling so the
inflation rate is a big deal for
policymakers and especially the Fed this
chart shows the inflation rate over the
past century you can see it's become
less volatile in recent decades the feds
long stated goal is to keep inflation at
about two percent not too high and not
too low but now they're worried the rate
drifted below two percent too often and
they're rethinking the strategy we'll
explain why but first let's look at what
causes inflation in the first place
[Music]
there's a lot of debate and few
certainties when it comes to what causes
inflation but here are some of the
bigger theories out there one is
increased demand inflation can occur
when there's an increase in demand in
goods and services all over the economy
from households to businesses to the
government many factors can drive up
demand higher incomes more access to
credit greater government spending and
more what's important to know is that
when demand grows faster than supply
businesses can raise their prices
this type of inflation may occur in a
growing economy supply pressures can
also drive inflation when the cost of
doing business goes up companies need to
raise prices to protect their profit
margins higher wages higher land costs
and tariffs can all make running a
company more expensive and lead to
inflation The Economist Milton Friedman
once said that inflation is always and
everywhere a monetary phenomenon he was
talking about the Fed the Fed is a major
factor in inflation it dictates the
supply of money in the economy and
changes interest rates which are the
cost of borrowing money by changing
interest rates the Fed can influence how
many cars homes or machines American
households and businesses buy and that
affects whether prices go up a lot or a
little when the Fed lowers rates loans
become more attractive to consumers they
borrow more to start businesses buy cars
and homes and spend more on consumer
goods which can drive up demand and
increase inflation on the flip side the
Fed raises rates to limit demand and
keep inflation in check usually if
inflation starts to pick up the Fed
considers raising interest rates to
limit borrowing the hope is that this
could keep the economy from overheating
and keep inflation down they did this 4
times in 2018 economists warned that an
increase in inflation can lead people to
expect even more leading to a spiral
they worried this could lead to a period
in which wages rise sharply pushing up
business costs and forcing further price
increases this is what happened in the
1970s when inflation rose as high as 12%
earlier this week President Nixon issued
an inflation alert inflation is now
expected to rise by 7 percent this year
the tyranny of double-digit inflation is
our common enemy people were terrified
it's worth noting that this phenomenon
is largely absent today because of
global labor markets when wages at home
rise companies can hire overseas also
when things heat up the Fed is quick to
raise rates and limit borrowing another
reason economists often prefer low
inflation is that it makes it easier for
people to make accurate long-term
financial decisions like starting a
business or buying a home if you know
how much your money will be worth in 1
year 2 years and Beyond you can plan
with that in mind but most economists
argue that the economy needs some
inflation to stay in balance moderate
inflation gives the economy a cushion in
case of a downturn if inflation is
already low policymakers worry a
recession could cause it to dip below
zero a phenomenon known as deflation
when inflation Falls and wages follow
people have less money to pay off their
debts and start to hoard their money
when people hoard their money that means
less spending and investing which can
make a recession worse or prolonged
so what's happening right now inflation
has been below the feds target for a
long time right now some Fed officials
want to let it rise above the 2% target
to make up for lost ground they say it's
likely they'll keep interest rates much
lower than in the past a necessary
measure to keep the economy growing
the feds benchmark short-term rate could
peak at or slightly above the current
range between 2.25 percent and two and a
half percent such low rates leave the
Fed less room than in the past to cut
rates when the economy hits a rough
patch
remember the Fed lowers rates to
stimulate growth and keep inflation
around that 2% mark in each of the last
three downturns the Fed lowered rates
roughly five percentage points if rates
remain low and inflation remains low
that may not be possible the next time
around